buonasera buonasera a tutti e grazie a
te partenza di questo invito
grazie a tutta l'organizzazione questa
opportunità di parlarvi un po del lavoro
che facciamo io mi chiamo andrea mar
faccio parte di alterazioni video è un
collettivo artistico
siamo in cinque attivi da circa 13 anni
il collettivo disperso di noi vivono
negli stati uniti 1 milano e due berlino
siamo tutti italiani però è incompiuto
siciliano il progetto di cui vi parlerò
oggi è uno di quelli che nel corso di
questi anni abbiamo realizzato e
cercando un po di mettere insieme questa
presentazione per oggi e cercando un po
di informazione oltre a quelle che
abbiamo di quanto poteva essere stato
pubblicato ultimamente che magari ci era
sfuggito è a me era sfuggita esattamente
questa pagina qua allora chiesa e today
sul sito di us and to the ieri sera mi
compare questa cosa
il parco archeologico dell'incompiuto
siciliano è stato messo all'interno di
una creativa dei 10 posti nascosti più
interessanti da vedere al mondo che
cos'è il parco archeologico
dell'incompiuto siciliano è la messa a
sistema del patrimonio di opere
pubbliche incompiute presenti a giarre
un comune nella provincia di catania un
comune di 30 mila abitanti che ha sul
proprio territorio
nove opere incompiute
fatto dato per il quale è stato nominato
capitale dell'incompiuto in italia
questo non da noi ma già da una
quindicina d'anni
ecco noi siamo andati dal sindaco di
giarre a proporgli di istituire questo
parco un dove poter costruire avere un
percorso che si sovrappone a quello
della città nella quale possibile
visitare il teatro iniziato a costruire
è mai finito negli anni 50 il parcheggio
multipiano il parco chico mendes è lo
stato di atletica che uno stadio da polo
la casa per anziani il centro
polifunzionale la piscina olimpionica il
mercato dei fiori la pista delle
macchinine non appartengono a questa
lista alle case popolari un centro
sociale e un altro pacchetto sono stati
presi per pazzi chiaramente dal sindaco
di giarre e in un certo è un primo
momento proprio una difficoltà di
comunicazione perché non era chiaro se
eravamo lì per provocare se eravamo
libera in qualche modo rovistare nelle
loro cose ma in mentre noi abbiamo
sempre avuto un atteggiamento molto
serio e propositivo
pensiamo che il fenomeno dell'incompiuto
in italia debba essere oggi storicizzato
e bisogna iniziare a fare una dare una
lettura di quanto è successo nel corso
degli ultimi 40 anni nel nostro paese
per poter iniziare a sviluppare delle
nuove strategie di intervento anche
estremamente laterali potremmo dire
potremmo dire come quella di istituire
un parco c'è un'offerta turistica che
tanto sembra che per quanto sembra
essere di zarra qui l'italia viene presa
dagli americani come una cosa
interessante
facciamo un passo indietro questo è
stato annunciato questo è un progetto
che in corso da dieci anni il prossimo
erano dieci anni e questo è stato un
certo punto uno degli atti 1 delle
azioni fatte a circa quattro anni
dall'inizio del progetto di cosa parli
di cosa parliamo
penso che lo abbiate capito sono opere
pubbliche incompiute grandi opere per
esempio in un raffronto di questo tipo
possiamo già iniziare ad avere una
prospettiva di quanto del tempo quando
parliamo di grande opere mettendo in
relazione il teatro nuovo di giarre che
a 50 anni con la costruzione della
piramide di cheope che ha impiegato 33
anni si ci avviciniamo praticamente a
battere il record della grande muraglia
cinese per cui abbiamo una prospettiva
nel tempo veramente molto ampia di
quelli sono gli esempi del delle opere
di cui parliamo sono centri sportivi
dighe palestre case popolari centri
polifunzionali ospedali viadotti
depuratori stadi teatri case di cura per
anziani alberghi centri sociali mercato
ittico del pesce dogana golf club
viadotti pista di atletica
no questo a scusare pista di equitazione
questo non l'abbiamo capito che cos'è
ponti palasport un cimitero un velodromo
un ascensore parcheggi multipiano scuole
non esiste tipologia costruttiva che non
abbia un esempio di opera pubblica
incompiuta
il progetto si chiama incompiuto
siciliano perché in sicilia è tipico
però noi abbiamo lavorato su tutto il
territorio nazionale perché ognuno di
noi ha la memoria il racconto
l'esperienza di un'opera incompiuta ma
che nel proprio territorio
c'è una produzione di comunicazione e di
opere incompiute quotidiana sui giornali
sui rotocalchi sulle riviste sui
programmi il più grande il più grande
esperto di opere incompiute l'italia
oggi al gabibbo striscia la notizia è
uno dei per esempio dei database che
raccoglie il maggior numero di opere
compiute per cui un uno degli spazi
online di conoscenza del fenomeno più
importanti che abbiamo in italia
noi abbiamo cercato di fare con tutto il
massimo rispetto ma abbiamo cercato di
fare un lavoro un po diverso dal gabibbo
e perciò la prima cosa che abbiamo fatto
è inizia a raccontarle questo nel 96
scusate nel 2006 e mettendole online
incompiuto siciliano doc tord slash
opere si accede a questa pagina
che da un attimo l'elenco si può
cliccare chiaramente su ognuna di queste
colonnine si apre una scheda le
segnalazioni è un sito open come user
content si usa dire cioè chiunque può
registrarsi a fare una propria
segnalazione compilare una scheda e
aggiungerne una colonnina cinque anni
dopo questo lavoro questa messa online
dell'archivio è stato istituito il simon
sistema integrato monitoraggio opere
incompiute presso il ministero delle
infrastrutture dei lavori pubblici
istituito dal governo letta dal governo
monti scusate
riceve le segnalazioni dalle regioni
italiane e ogni anno compila un elenco
andando a formare l'anagrafe delle opere
pubbliche incompiute in italia allora
nel nostro database ci sono 650 opere
incompiute in quello del sì noi ce ne
sono circa 882 database insieme ne
condividono 25 cioè ne condivide noi
abbiamo delle opere incompiute presenti
in ugual misura
sono 25 quindi sono più che un migliaio
perché noi non consideriamo per esempio
molte delle segnalazioni che fanno le
regioni che considerano ristrutturazioni
varianti di progetto conversioni di un
edificio in qualcos'altro che rimane
incompiuto per cui insieme ne abbiamo 25
e le nostre 600 allora non più 50
diciamo 40 insieme all 800
molti 80 ma 60 fanno più di un migliaio
bello è che sono ancora molte di più e
nessuno sa esattamente quante opere
incompiute ci siano in italia oggi ed è
difficile avere un'immagine di questo
fenomeno punto per questa
parcellizzazione frantumazione a livello
percettivo che abbiamo no della presenza
di queste opere incompiute sul
territorio se noi proviamo qui a a
tenere in considerazione solo le opere
incompiute togliendo tutto il resto
allora otteniamo l'immagine questa
immagine è quella di una italia
incompiuta è quella di un italia
che non esiste che è stata però pagata
tantissimo e stata un'idea anche di
progresso che non si e mai realizzato
una tensione alla modernità al che è
stata un'illusione
l'aver incompiuta noi appaiono come
buchi neri sul territorio cioè luoghi
che non posso non sono frequentabili
cantieri aperti e che rappresentano una
porzione di territorio inaccessibile e
separata completamente scollegata dal
resto delle relazioni sociali umane e
come fare a raccontare tutto questo come
far uscire da quella narrazione
mainstream quotidiana che abbiamo sui
giornali del programmi di
intrattenimento nelle riviste nelle
pubblicazioni che si succedono al giorno
dopo giorno mese dopo mese anno dopo
anno come uscire fuori da questa da
questa i prin osi collettiva quali
faccio parte tutti è allora l'idea è
quella di costruire una nuova narrazione
noi chiamiamo questa nuova narrazione
incompiuto siciliano e dichiariamo che
in italia esiste uno stile
architettonico che si chiama incompiuto
siciliano che è più importante stile
architettonico degli ultimi 40 anni dal
dopoguerra ad oggi abbiamo scritto un
manifesto dello stile compiuto siciliano
è il paradigma interpretativo
dell'architettura pubblica in italia dal
dopoguerra ad oggi pare incredibile come
il numero di opere incompiute
sul territorio possa generare un
programma ideologico uno stile il
dipendente dalla volontà dei propri
progettisti la dimensione del fenomeno
l'estensione territoriale le incredibili
peculiarità architettoniche fanno di
compiuto siciliano il più importante
stile architettonico italiano agli
ultimi 40 anni
sono due i dati dato che ci permettono
di affermare questo statement questa
dichiarazione il numero un dato
quantitativo è un dato qualitativo cioè
gli elementi ricorrenti nei siti che noi
abbiamo visitato di tutte le opere
incompiute elementi colori materiali
come la presenza di vegetazione l'umano
e completamente estromesso non esiste
presenza umana non esiste neanche
memoria in questi luoghi non sono mai
stati
null'altro che ho per il computer non
c'è storia è un tempo sospeso perché
avevo iniziato ad analizzare proprio le
caratteristiche peculiari di questi
luoghi
laddove nessuno solitamente va ma perché
nessuno ha interesse ad andare in un
cantiere chiuso da trent'anni allora le
rovine computer sono rovine
contemporanee nate come tali nascono in
quanto rovine monumenti generati dall
entusiasmo creativo del liberismo nel
momento in cui no il la nostra la
necessità di una società è quella di
produrre a realizzare profitti
attraverso per esempio il comparto
edilizio benissimo
uno dei risultati e anche la produzione
di opere incompiute la natura e poi
succedono tutta una serie di cose
all'interno di questi luoghi come la
natura che per mezzo della vegetazione
spontanea dialoga sinesteticamente con
le opere incompiute riappropriandosi dei
luoghi e ridefinendo il paesaggio perché
il paesaggio italiano
oggi è quello che abbiamo visto
nell'immagine
il fenomeno delle opere incompiute non
ha soltanto condizionato le coscienze di
un di un'intera società ma ne ha
modellato anche i confini fisici di un
intero territorio ridefinendo quello che
oggi il nostro paesaggio nel compiuto
siciliano tensione tra forma e funzione
si risolve ecco che il difetto dell'uso
si trasforma in opera d'arte
perché uno degli elementi fondamentali
dell'architettura e la relazione tra
forma e funzione quando questa è scissa
è che cosa solo è difficile anche
identificarle e l'unico esempio che noi
venuto in mente dove forma e funzione
sono slegati sono opere è l'opera d'arte
noi in quanto artisti quello facciamo lo
facciamo un oggetto non è che deve
servire qualcosa è un'opera d'arte
e allora quella piscina che ha fatta
forma di piscina non è una piscina è
un'opera d'arte frutto del lo stile del
dell'incompiuto siciliano e noi
celebriamo gli artisti che non siamo noi
ma sono una serie di soggetti sono gli
amministratori ei politici
degli enti locali sono gli imprenditori
sono professionisti progettisti le
imprese e le comunità locali e le
comunità locali in tutta questa storia
fra lato curiosità non c'è un
responsabile
non c'è non è mai nessuno è stato mai
condannato per aver fatto un'opera
incompiuta ma perchè la responsabilità è
veramente collettiva in una follia che
noi abbiamo perseguito per quarant'anni
della storia di questo paese una piccolo
frammento però molto interessante come
angolo per vedere la storia di questo
paese
il compito siciliano è fondato su
un'etica e un'estetica propria
l'incompiuto siciliano è il simbolo del
potere politico e di una sensibilità
artistica
finisco brevemente che cosa facciamo noi
a questo punto definendo avendo studiato
il fenomeno avendolo definito in un
paradigma interpretativo avendo prodotto
tutta una serie di opere che hanno
girato biennale di venezia shenzhen in
cina brasile workshop sono fatte le tesi
di laurea
abbiamo fatto un festival dentro le
opere incompiute tre giorni di follia
collettiva molto divertente
abbiamo iniziato adesso a progettarle
insomma che facciamo quelli punto adesso
con queste opere incompiute hanno
fondamentalmente si possono fare quattro
cose si possono primo finire là dove è
possibile questa cosa tenendo conto del
periodo che è trascorso
se la struttura è in effetti dopo 30
anni ancora permette ancora la
possibilità di essere completata
finiamola le ricorrenze condo le
riconvertiamo ad altro uso
cambiamo la destinazione d'uso non è più
una piscina diventa uno skatepark
bellissimo in california lo fanno da
sempre quello stadio da poi cioè quello
stadio da polo e non è più non stare ma
poi lo quello che non è mai stata una
seria per le gradinate sono troppo
inclinate non sarà mai uno stadio da
polo allora però offre una copertura
pazzesca
no l'unica in tutto il paese per farci
un mercato coperto per esempio belvedere
dei capri nel quartiere capre di napoli
per esempio che questo viadotto che
spacca in due il quartiere è offre una
meravigliosa vista sull'isla sul golfo
di napoli per cui terza cosa le lasciamo
così come sono con toccano più niente
non serve sono già abbiamo già fatto
tanto ha speso tanti soldi vanno bene
anche così questo è un bel vedere
bellissimo ci offre la possibilità poi
non lo so
possiamo metterci un farlo un parco
giochi
no anche quando un mercato coperto e
vedete no lui finisce qua però sotto c'è
tutta questa zona verde bellissima e no
che potrebbe porti comuni parchi urbani
insomma ci facciamo il cinema non lo so
ci possiamo fare perché non ci possiamo
fare il cinema all'aperto
ecco la quarta cosa l le buttiamo giù
perché no le buttiamo giù è da sempre
storia dell'architettura della stu della
costruzione usare le macerie per
costruire altre cose problema è che
molte c'è ci sono i costi di demolizione
e smaltimento dei rifiuti bonifica dei
terreni per cui molti comuni non non
hanno la disponibilità soprattutto per
esempio in un esempio come quello di
raccontare quando un comune a nove opere
incompiute sul proprio territorio
cosa fa ma poi io vi vorrei portare
nella diga di blufi nella diga di e
rosalpina nella diga laurea cioè in
questi luoghi meravigliosi sicilia
bellissimi dove sono state sbancate
dell'inter e valli per fare queste dighe
di cemento cosa facciamo lì non si
possono demolire queste cose vanno
lasciate e allora per chiudere e giunto
il momento di fare i conti con questo
passato uscire fuori dal ipnosi
collettiva che ce ne fa ad inviduare una
23 no sono tante sono migliaia e bisogna
caso per caso iniziare a riprogettare
questi luoghi
avendo una articolazione di interventi e
di strategie di intervento aperta a
varie possibilità uscire fuori dal dal
dall'ideologia de les finiamo perché non
le potremmo mai finire tutte tutto
questo questa visione noi deriva dal
fatto semplicemente di aver trovato un
punto di osservazione su il mondo in
questo caso sulle opere incompiute aver
costruito una narrazione che oggi ci
permette di rileggere in questo modo
ecco questo è quanto è possibile fare
nel nel mondo reale oggi assume una
posizione di lettura delle cose da una
prospettiva diversa che ci permettono di
leggere le stesse cose in una forma
nuova
questo è quello che abbiamo provato a
fare noi andiamo avanti il prossimo anno
siamo con la pubblicazione
quest'anno infatti tra un paio di mesi e
faccio lo spot forse lo sport siamo la
campagna in crowdfounding per cui chi lo
saprà donerà e io vi ringrazio del tempo
che vi ho occupato